bien oui sage créé international non
Je ne le connaissais pas maintenant oui je le connais déjà
bien j'envoie un salut à tous
Vénézuéliens, je ne pense pas savoir quoi
radio canada international existe mais
je vais lancer la pub
mes réseaux sociaux pour qu'ils soient
sachez que votre nom est alejandro reno
alejandro rendón de quel pays colombien
et qu'est-ce qui t'amène aujourd'hui à la radio que rien non
Je voulais savoir que tu étais en visite
Je voulais faire quelque chose et j'ai découvert que
il y a eu cet événement de regarder pour voir ce
ça vient et tu sais radio canada
international si je le dis sur facebook
et sur les réseaux sociaux ensuite
ils m'apportent toujours les prochaines nouvelles
Eh bien, nous sommes au jour des portes
ouvert sur radio canada international et
nous sommes avec sara sara d'où ça vient
Sara je suis de Montréal parce que j'ai un
petite famille espagnole et bien sûr
Je veux voyager un peu des pays
l'espagnol et j'ai un ami qui vient de
Colombie alors c'est très facile de parler
espagnol avec lui
saviez-vous de radio canada international non
pas vraiment parce que je suis à Montréal
alors quand est-ce que je vois le
la télévision est en français ou en anglais
nous avons déjà des programmes en français
en anglais sur la chaîne radio
international
et en espagnol et en espagnol et mandarin
en arabe fort c'est vrai mon nom est
sarah et écoutent radio canada
international
bonne journée gérée et je vais passer un
fantastique jour après jour cette culture
à radio canada
les tables pour bébés sont également
amuser des montagnes d'activité et est un
jour des portes obertes très
intéressant merci merci je m'appelle
María Carolina et ils écoutent le
radio canada international parce qu'ici le
permet à bien des égards
montrer à quel point vous pouvez vous amuser dans un
endroit qui pour les yeux serait froid
J'invite tous mes proches amis et
comme une Latina qui profite d'une ville
comme lundi nous avons beaucoup à faire
offre et une région comme ce que vous voyez est
grande radio canada prospère
international